для вас сьогодні сюрприз
взагалі багато сюрпризів
Олексійовича знову в дорозі на фронт з
якими думками їдете роз
кажіть
бо я вам хочу сказати що на фронті якось
легше дихається це унікальна відчуття
тут все абсолютно чітко є ворог
справжній є друзі
надійні є герої
справжні українські
[музика]
і все чітко розумієш що де коли і як
треба робити
і тому
чи сказати що ті хто у нас
Вжик вже їздили звик вже їздити хто
Ага получається що ти вже тиждень 10
днів не на півдні не на сході
Ти вже знаходиш собі і завершуєш той чи
інший проект
Я теж на світі Сьогодні у нас дуже
знакало поїздка
ми про неї поговоримо
нові пікапи L200
завершуємо проект передачі сьогодні 81-й
бригаді його це побачити
дуже крутий проект
бойових бджілок
готелів в тому числі і з нічним баченням
дуже-дуже позитивні відгуки від бойового
застосування Хочу наголосити що ми не
просто передаємо
дрони збройним силам ми
зберігаємо зв'язок
ми маємо яким чином нам покращити
модельний
ряд бойове застосування програмне
забезпечення
і це вже такий міцний зв'язок з нашими
партне
рами
з бойових бригад дрони у нас
зараз не знаю через триває його таєм
ницю десантним бригади у нас ідуть по 25
років
і
тих і тих і це означає що в кожному
бойовому взводі
буде один і
ми налагодили систему Коли командир
бригади буде мати повну картинку по
всьому
наступу полосі або оборона або ключове
Контрнаступ
Контрнаступ - це те чим зараз живе кожен
українець Да ми не Приймаємо рішення
військові зараз я вже не є верховним
головнокомандувачем А на своєму місці я
і Кожен член моєї команди робить
максимум можливо для того щоб
забезпечити контракт
всі зараз цим живемо Ну багато спілку
єтесь воїнами нашими на фронті розкажіть
не на картоплю те що вони говорять я
розкажу на камеру але те що вони
говорять на камеру і не на камеру трохи
відрізняється
що мене дивує
що добре
володіють інформацією
яким чином забезпечується
збройні поставки України і кожен раз
коли я розповідаю ситуацію що ми робимо
що країна робить і
в першу чергу вони просять мене передати
слова подяки
нашим партнерам американцям британцям в
даному випадку італійцями
полякам
балтійцям і великий кількості наших
партнерів які забезпечують ефективну
сьогодні вночі
в Харкові на території Харківської
області
ми мали зустріч з двома різними
батальйонами які тримають оборону силами
спецоперацій Я пишаюся що зі силами були
створені мною мій підпис стоїть під
указом Президента про створення сил
спеціальних операцій так
вони вже відрізняють що вже є
західні гаубів цих Західна артилерія
наскільки більш точніше вони вже Всі
розуміють більш точніше б'є
Західна натівська між колишні Радянська
особливо поєднанні з величезною
майстерністю
українських артилерійських це поєднання
відбувається
дуже важливій позиції коли які
підкреслюються це є нова війна позиція
перша це є сучасна високоточна
далекобійна парта позиція друга це є очі
арти дрони позиція третя - це є засоби
радіоелектронної
наскільки щоб там не попав ніхто в кадр
кого не можна а ви мені поки скажіть то
нарізати будуть вони росіянам чи ні Що
говорять уже не треба чекати
будь ласка Донецька область З
поверненням команди в Донецьку область
я хочу вас розчарувати
перше вони вже нарізають
і не буде знаєте такого
широкомасштабного в 12 годин ночі
вся країна піднялася пішла в
широкомасштабний наступ і всіх Там
викинули всіх перемогли це у нас в уявах
штатних
брехунів які лише дезорієнтуються в
суспільстві А ті хто буває і був на
фронті Вони знають що буквально
вигризають
кожне село
кожне 100 метрів
наступу
і
знають ціну яку ми платимо за це дуже
добре і якісна підготовлена Бри гада до
штурму
потребує не лише власної підготовки а і
дуже ефективної координації з
артилерією
дуже ефективною координації з розвідкою
дуже ефективно як координації засоби
нерепа для того щоб опустити ворожі
безпілотники зараз це буде ще
дуже важлива позиція і як на мене
Ми дуже добре вирішуємо ми не треба
нам треба забезпечити Контрнаступ кожен
На своїй ділянці але пріоритет як ми вже
сказали це Правобережна
Херсонська область там воює
частина в створенні який я брав
безпосередню участь
і дуже щасливий що
на сьогоднішній день ми маємо
героїчні вчинки наших бійців але але
за останні 10 днів були дуже важкими бо
Я особисто свого кола втратив дуже
багато друзів помічників членів нашої
команди починаючи від хліба бабічів
справжні герої
і
ми завжди про них будемо пам'ятати і
весняна за їх смерть точно таксі це вже
стало щось особистим
буде важка зима
я
нічого нового не скажу якщо зараз просто
повторюся зима буде важка Але нам треба
її зробити легше ключова складова це не
є
термінове будівництво доріг
якихось там багатоповерхівок в нас немає
іншого завдання ніж перемога і
витрачайні коштів немає іншого напрямку
ніж збройні сили України Я про це
говорив за півроку до війни нас зараз
уже всі виявляються всі знали що
буде вчили вони відрізняються від
російських фейків я
не можу собі уявити
я наголошую що за два дні до початку
війни уже Після рішення Путіна про
визнання ЛНР ДНР
нам
на погоджувальній раді керівництво
парламенту всі намагалися переконати що
нічого не буде
І лише
Лють українців
майстерність збройних сил
зробили неймовірне
питання хочу
Ірина ваша не поїхала спочатку
повномасштабного вторгнення як багато
жінок
Чесно кажучи думаю що Про це треба
питати в неї
бо
вперше
хвилини війни я її сказав що я поїхав
збираюся
весь в Києві виїжджаю
і ти з ним
є реакція мені запам'ятається на все
життя вона була дуже здивована
і не допускали навіть думки
такої єдине що попросили що
десь знайти камуфляж і розмір
і видати її зброю
справжня українка
Я дуже тішився і пишаюся що 38 років
тому я не помилився коли обрав саме таку
дружину бойову патріотичну
професійно і коли вона вже через дві
години
на знову організовані кухні
почала
керувати підготовкою їжі
для добровольців які прийшли записувати
всі в територіального оборони міста
Києва організувала дівчат
разом з нашою службою тела
організувала підвезення продуктів
з координувала
благодійну допомогу
медичну
догнав мене лікар кандидата
з нею легше
переносити тягати військовою
це те що ми будемо передавати те що ми
будемо передавати наші 81-й А оце не
тільки 81-й це йде нашим протитанковим
підрозділом
дуже круто
А оце і наші десантники
будемо завершувати інтерв'ю і підемо до
хлопців Дякую Петра Олексійович дуже
приємно